[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge here in st. Louis for their
2017 winter chess classic hello chest
fans and welcome back to st. Louis the
st. Louis chess club is very proud to
present the first of four seasonal
tournaments in 2017 this winter chess
classic pits 20 players from 10
different nations against each other in
two different fields join me for the
next week as I recap the tournament each
day and talk to the players and have
them analyzed their own game and with
the talent in this tournament they're
sure to be some bloodshed on the board
these players will earn top-level
tournament experience but also there's a
twenty-thousand-dollar prize fund at
stake the winner of group a Mets five
thousand dollars the winner of groupie
that's four thousand dollars alright
this weekend in round two grand master
photo save here from Russia played Grand
Master a pataga and he came out with a
victory congratulations on that victory
I was like oh yeah and and it's your
first victory of the tournament we've
got nine rounds here so take us through
this game here in any keep parts of it
and it has to place this position it is
right every time I ingest it James said
that its sequel 45 smooth and what why
why don't get the table but it's not not
not easy to find something here also i
can play hope I've given here might be
nice before
96 is a fat and something like this
before it's almost so clear but I think
that a text before is also possible but
I don't remember any variations there
after 88 XP five diction before hear of
the hook given better then hook everyone
everyone was probably its first mistake
in this game after night 56 and so what
to do is wipe sir nida folks looks good
after green jade bottoms up 96 check be
56 change we should be seven I can play
just a bit and take on the five if if I
want to play if evora physics it's not
matter i just taken my friend my phone
is sometimes it's probably even position
for black
k
like the four green jade green jade
[Music]
looks normal we should be 550 95 and so
I hope to play the same game without any
risk public because this phone is the
weight and I have a nice reliable cake
there can say some something like this
we should be 695 and then just to put my
phone down as much as I can he decided
to sacrifice this is a nice digs it
means that after green tea seven buckets
probably lost after can be 686 be 60
create check King c7 is on the move
because that they can be seven here too
okay one simple checkmate
and then I don't give any chance to my
opponent this position was absolutely
hopeless provide I actually and then I
placed very well right this guy won the
aeroflot open this year so he is a big
deal you might say and you also brought
up a good point that I failed to mention
being a 9round round-robin tournament
well half of the field has to get five
blacks a patil gets five lights so you
got kind of the raw deal there but so
far you know we're early on it remains
to be seen what will happen well
Vladimir thank you very much for joining
me and let's take a look at the
standings after the first two rounds in
Group A in Group A four players share
the top spot with one and a half points
each this is to be expected as we're
only two rounds in here are the pairings
for round three to be played on Monday
March thirteenth alright I'm here with
Grandmaster Irina Krush who today took
on another one of the club's favorites
Grandmaster alejandro ramirez she has
the white pieces and came out victorious
congratulations i arena on that take us
through the game now why just completed
development so is it black but
unfortunately there is some you know
problems in blacks position with the
sensor the sensor belongs to white and
this move 95 is really unpleasant the
bishop is trapped into a trade there's
actually two threats here there's a
threat of night takes d6 like for
example if King 88 which I was thinking
could happen now this simple move it's
very unpleasant not just because you're
getting the bishop but even the move
Bishop e5 and it looks like black is
losing the c7 pawn v6 is hanging so
after 95 I honestly just didn't really
see any moves for black can't escape
with the bishop 96 is a threat and one
more threat was on the board which I
just think that Alejandro missed he
played this move with the idea that if i
take the bishop he could take with the
night and it's not so bad
it's at least playable but he simply
miss to the move Knight takes e7 and can
take it because the king is in the wrong
position there's a discovery so he had
to play down a pawn so i don't think
i've ever gotten quite so much so early
on in the game against it's a strong
player so of course this is not a
typical mistake for someone like
alejandro to make but i think that you
know maybe I mean blacks position is
right here is really quite bad you know
and that c c e takes d5 capture was
really the culprit and that's why you
know this kind of blunder came up just
because his heart sir finds a move here
so then it was basically about
conversion and i had to show some kind
of technique which i don't think i did a
great job of probably in this position i
really should have just taken this
bishop and of course my night was strong
and I wasn't quite sure here there's
some ideas of like black playing be 59
th c4 but still somehow my feeling is
like this must be the way to go it's
pretty it's really pretty simple I mean
there's some chances and the bishops of
opposite color here well like in this
case is this trade but it's hard to
believe that this is not just a winning
position for white so I think I should
have done that but I decided to keep all
these pieces on the board centralized
the Queen forced this move went back the
reason I did that was there wasn't going
to be night c5 here at every turn and no
a for ideas and then try to centralize
my pieces age three just like some kind
of consolidating moves queen 86 black is
trying to get counselor play yeah I
can't say that you know i felt like i
was playing all that convincingly at
this point pawn takes Queen takes
obviously there's threats on f2 so I
decided the night should go back but
white still got everything under control
still the move like
ad1 was useful and now this is a 5 is an
idea the sub C 1 is an idea so black
doesn't I mean by the way of course you
know this position you're always looking
at this after especially after f4 you're
always looking at this square very
important square and you're making sure
there's no tactics on it and somehow you
know white just has enough coordination
hear that no tactics work and you know
like this move for example might look a
little bit scary but there's a move
Bishop g4 breaking the pin so the rook
is it's good that it's a shoes they're
on s1 not a passive rook they're very
useful so alejandra didn't see all that
much to do here played 95 well now we're
follow the principle of trading pieces
and it's really time to now trade off
this guy on c5 because I've left him on
the board and he's a little bit
dangerous so we did a maneuver to trade
him now if black trades here was going
to take with the clean and play this end
game with an extra pawn 96 as a threat
so I thought this should be you know
technically winning I mean of course
black and carry on with something like
night efore alejandra played bit of a 6
which surprised me a little bit so I
took this chance to get the other look
into the game and threaten Bishop c5
discovery he had to move away and this
was like kind of the critical moment in
terms of duh you know wrapping up stage
there's some little tricks in this
position and I don't know I was also I
guess there's some move like Knight b6
which is kind of interesting 96 right
away and I'm Bishop c4 and Knight g4
actually looks pretty good for me but I
was really tempted by just move Bishop
c5 forcing move rook takes and night d6
and why did I go for this at first I
thought it was impossible because
there's rugby 5 and that was kind of the
trap the black was setting
that you know due to this pin he can
take the pawn but then I saw I actually
have this Queen sacrifice for the rook
and the night and soon the bishop so
White's pieces are really interacting
beautifully here and the poor Queen it
really has no squares on this diagonal
and she's got one normal square like
this I mean odd of course if you're not
careful as black you might i'd say
there's all kinds of tactics here you
know using the back rink idea so the
Queen's had moved to normal square like
g6 and white simply captures and I just
thought that this was an adequate
position to go for rook in two pieces
good coordination safe King may now
working to peaches are better than a
queen and especially if the king is safe
and the structure is sound and you know
I've got outposts of an outpost this is
going to be an outpost for the bishop
and eventually white we'll just
coordinate those pieces and she should
win the game so that was my big you know
a moment of calculation in this game
that allowed me to play the move Knight
b6 and I think Alejandro saw that and
that's why he traded but that was really
like my dream is just to make that
capture the night on d6 is really
powerful and the rook is basically just
trapped so the 96 wins the game here and
again we follow the rule of trading
pieces when you're up material and not
much chances for black in this position
because he can never undermine White's
formation with this move b5 it's simply
losses upon and in this move there's you
know not pawn takes Knight but rook
takes leaves white up a piece so there's
not that much the black can do here he
tried actually a four you might wonder
about them revolt because we were
thinking the same way actually my next
move would have been pawn to a4 to make
sure blacks aw bpong could never move so
that's why Alejandra tried this move the
problem here though is that white is not
just up a pawn but also has this
dominance night and there's a weakness
b6 so there's an owl weakness on a four
so we just kind of bring in those pieces
and now I thought let's bring in the
king I actually envisioned him all the
way on d4 you know getting all the
pieces into the game and attacking was
pawned forcing this and just bringing it
in and black can barely move anything we
even took that square away like
permanently so he tried this move but
you know we had the tactics prepared
with the idea that after all the
captures on b6 there was going to be
nite CH and Knight takes rook and then
even winning a third pawn on a force oh
so that's what happens in this game well
Irena congratulations on your victory in
round two against Alejandro in Group B
now there's a lot of strong competition
in Group E how do you see the rest of
this field playing out against you well
you know of course I'm taking it one
game at a time rice I mean there's no
point looking too far ahead everyone is
really strong and you know I am see I
feel happy just to get this opportunity
to play it's a solid field you know I
mean I'm one of the lower rated players
but I think it's going to be really good
process for the US Championship and
speaking of the US Championship seven
times over the US Women's Champion is
Irina Krush now last year nie trzeba
keep they turned the scene on its head
what do you think about your prospects
in the US Women's Championship you
coming back for it well um I'm coming
back for it yes but i think this
tournament depend you know will kind of
influence a lot you know just like how i
managed to get myself into song playing
form here you know so really this is a
good opportunity for me I don't play as
much as I used to and when I got the
invitation to come here I immediately
you know agree just like within you know
five minutes I already sense in my
acceptance to come here because I knew
that it was just going to be so
important to get that playing practicing
and
think you know and of course it's kind
of this tournament is even going to be
you know stronger in terms of actual you
know level compared to u.s. women's
championship so starting out with a
really tough event and hopefully you
know um that's going to be you know what
you need is a lot of these this is a
start of a new series quarterly series
season will have the Summer Classic to
spring classic so on and so forth so I
think a lot of players are going to get
that tuna preparation in this very
strong environment Irena thank you so
much for joining me thank you and let's
take a look at group B standings after
two rounds of play chess club resident
Grandmaster Christian carrilla stands
sole leader in Group B with two points
and unblemished performance so far here
are tomorrow's pairings for group B the
2017 winter chess classic runs every day
through sunday March 19 rounds begin at
one p.m. each day except for the final
round see the games live as they happen
on us chess champ calm and chest 24.com